okay
[Music]
I want to fly ah let's do this yeah
you gotta force it to come out what are
you
you're a genius I know what'd I say
yes oh did you know what was gonna
happen to my brother when you stuck him
with this world destroying thing
it's called the Scarab
I had no idea it would activate it has
to choose you
so how do we get it to unchoose me
who said that systems
[Music]
foreign
but I swear
the world is a place to protect I have
an Arsenal at my disposal had anything
pleased
I can create yeah that's more like it
hello you feel for your family makes you
weak you're wrong my family that's what
makes me strong
oh I forgot how bad it looks
Target the family
[Music]
sorry my mama
you are our superhero come on
you're the Blue Beetle if I could use
that Arsenal right about now God you
never asked oh yeah
Bust It Down bust it down
I advise me back away
town